-During a radio interview
last night,
former Chicago Bears coach
Mike Ditka
weighed in on the recent
national anthem protest.
Ditka said...
Here to comment is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth!
Now, former Chicago Bears' coach
Mike Ditka said,
"There hasn't been
any oppression
in the last 100 years."
Which officially makes him
daa-worst!
[ Laughter ]
70% of NFL players are black.
How can you work with so many
black people and not know them?
Seth knows me.
Seth, what do I do
with my free time?
-You watch "Scandal"
and pretend you're Olivia Pope.
-Yep.
And what is my favorite food?
-Your favorite food
is margaritas.
[ Laughter ]
-Correct.
And what is it like to be
a black person in America?
-That is not something
I as a white person
am qualified to talk about.
But...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...from what I can glean,
not great?
-That is the correct answer.
And if you think things are
going great for black people,
you're on daa-wrong side
of history!
[ Laughter ]
Mike Ditka, what do you know
about oppression?
You won one Super Bowl in 1986,
and they gave you
your own steakhouse!
Charles Barkley was one of
the greatest basketball players
of all time
and all he got was fat.
[ Laughter ]
You think no bad things
have happened to black people
for 100 years?
Charlottesville happened
this summer!
And then, again, three days ago!
Ditka also said,
"If you want to kneel
during the national anthem,
you should go to another country
and play football."
What other country?
We're the only ones dumb enough
to spend our Sundays
wearing tights
and giving each other
brain damage.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, Jerry Jones threatened to
bench players
who protest the national anthem.
That is a white man
threatening his black players
with punishment if they exercise
their right to free speech.
Which can be found
in daa-Constitution.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Daa-Constitution.
Daa-Constitu--
I think it's not
all the way there.
Daa-Constitution!
Is it right?
-It's daa-fine.
[ Laughter ]
-In summary, Mike Ditka believes
that all players should stand
for the national anthem.
And I'm sure they will.
As soon as the anthem
stands for all players.
Daa-end!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Daa-end!
Amber Ruffin, everybody!